when you fully reflect on 2020 it
doesn't surprise me that we have this
level of
inflammatory discussion people talking
past each other and just
total the performative communication
everything it doesn't surprise you it
was a long time coming uh the the
twitter stuff i find really interesting
uh because it's how it's affecting the
media class
uh there was a leaked uh memo from the
daily beast where the
the high ups were trying to what they i
think was they were forbidding the use
of twitter during office hours
because they felt that twitter and it's
just i think broadly more
broadly accurate that twitter itself is
actually
doing damage to the journalistic
profession
because yeah i mean like like yeah
the the the and fake news is
being widely perpetrated by it like for
example when
the football lads went to defend the
statue of churchill uh the fake news
surrounding this and the misinformation
surrounding this is quite staggering
uh the claim that they're nazis is
not true and the proof of this
is in the fact that we're protesting
against a statue of winston churchill
being damaged
gary lineker or like you know some of
the famous football tweeted out going
why are these nazis trying to save the
statue of winston churchill it's like
well that's
the very fact you're asking the question
means you need to do more research
doesn't it gary
you know you should have looked in this
guy okay well hang on are these nazis
and they go oh no they're doing nazi
salutes and it's because there was a
side on uh picture you could see people
putting up their hands both hands like
this because they did you know they did
this clap
chant in the thing and they were
chanting england but from the side oh
you you can see how that might look like
a nazi salute
but that was and even people like julia
hartley brewer were
like repeating this and then there was
another fake bit of footage where
someone had
imposed over them uh the audio of
some white nationalist or national front
protest from like
2017 where they're chanting we're racist
and we like it
and this was again repeated everywhere
on the radio on lbc
i hurdled and it's like that wasn't true
you know the
the football lads there are many
failings again like with donald trump
you know many ethical failings of what
they've done
however they aren't nazis they are
actually kind of like you know the
post-world war ii british patriots you
know
they firmly believe that britain's role
in the war was a good thing they firmly
believe in winston churchill's
leadership
and they firmly believe in the narrative
that we were on the side of
side of right and not on the side of the
nazis and yet there they go look at
these nazis i
didn't know what we can do you know did
you see
the map of voters
in the uk that was shared just after the
general election
and it had who voted by age and it went
hyper viral on facebook and it basically
showed
that um the implication was
old people voted conservative that's how
boris got in power did you see this
yes that became
not only not only something that people
thought but
fully bullet like it was straight fact
and it was a map taken from 2017
2016 i think
really i didn't know that yes
see it's amazing how this stuff goes
viral and then creates the fake news
but it's just like some guy some fella
you know or some girl from
bristol
it was a fact but not in this particular
circumstance
but again like the fact that that is the
way
that the culture develops now should
terrify
everybody no matter what side you're
coming from yeah
so social media has been a curse that we
weren't ready for
um and i i mean it it's probable that
something similar to the effect that
we're seeing now would have happened
given enough time i think it's probably
inevitable uh given the philosophies and
you know them percolating through the
culture probably would have done
but i think social media is just
essentially an accelerating factor
that's just got everything to go so much
faster and like there was a study that
showed that twitter
activates the same parts of the brain as
being in a fight so when you get on
twitter you're in
fight mode oh no totally you might not
be moving but your heart's pumping
your adrenaline is going you and your
brain is is you know as you're like
arguing with someone on twitter you may
as well be going and have a fight with
that person so it's like okay
you're essentially stepping into the
world's largest fight club when you log
into twitter
and get ready to get punched because
everyone gets punched on twitter you
know what i mean
and so like it's just
it's not good
the problem is that the the
interpretation of the facts uh diverging
is fine
everyone expects a divergent view of the
interpretation of the facts
but because people are set in their
online echo chambers
and there can't really be any other way
of doing this apart from
having it so that you don't get to
choose what you follow
uh because when people get to choose
what they follow they follow the things
that they like
and that means they only get that
perspective one you know one view and so
it was that there was a plurality of
opinions on the same facts but now there
is not there's there's divergent facts
for each side
and i really wish when kellyanne conway
said other alternative facts
it was like haha there's no such thing
as alternative facts like yeah there are
there are facts you're not listening to
you're not paying attention to
like you know despite being 13 you know
that's a fact
that you didn't want to mention it's an
alternative fact
it's still real and yet you leave it out
of the narrative and so
it's you know it's it's it it's now at
the point where we don't even agree the
same things happened
you know the yeah the the the london
bubble is like oh there were nazi
salutes
people with video cameras didn't capture
any nazi salutes
these people do not profess to be nazis
and they wish the defendants to
churchill
what do we do
you